books are Zebina Honnold calling and
passion she's a graduate student in
history at the University of Erfurt
her studies have taken her as far away
as Japan but she's always kept a special
place in her heart for her hometown
effort spins a veena my name is Sabina
I'm from air foot and grew up here in
between I spent a few years in other
places as part of my studies but I
decided to come back because I really
love it here it's a beautiful city and a
good place to live it's become more
modern over the years but it's an old
city with a rich history and today I'm
going to show you a few of my favorite
places questions- that site we head to
the historic city center and Sabinas
first tip the veidt's biker theater
a narrow alley runs from the Cathedral
Square to the theater building which
dates back to the 16th century
you still for a much better I'm standing
in front of the visor it's our local
puppet theater they put on plays with
all sorts of puppets from stick puppets
to marionette in some of the pieces half
the cast of puppets it's really special
something not to be missed when I have
visitors this is where I like to bring
them so let's go in at once magical and
modern the fairytale theater is enjoyed
by young and old alike
the theater puts on about 300
performances each year sometimes the
audience gets to take a glimpse behind
the scenes all of the puppets are
handmade here at the theater
next we cross the Unger square to one of
the city's many medieval churches the
Vig mantequilla
yet Sega choice now I'm going to show
you a place that very few people here
know about it's behind this gate let's
go
Sabeena Hanna's second tip is the big
fatty Hoff communal center this is a
knob it's a bit hidden and so you don't
see many people here but I love it it's
like a green and wonderful Oasis I
discovered this place a few years ago
when the courtyard was restored they did
a lovely job with a fountain and this
enormous green tree once part of a
monastery the courtyard dates back to
the 12th century we continue on to
another central and yet hidden location
not far from the Gera River it's where
we find zappiness third tip the fixon
cafe known for its specialty coffees
it's a popular hangout for students I'm
in the fixon one of my favorite cafes in
the city it has good coffee good cakes
good food and many regional delicacies
it's right in the middle of town it's
small and cozy I really like that and
I'm happy that cafe opened up here right
behind the Kramer bridge
the folks in cafe opened in 2009 the
owner and barista is Thomas Schindler a
true master of the art of coffee making
so when you sip a coffee here at cafe
fukcing it's not just a hot drink but a
labor of love